in this video i'm going to explain to
you exactly why the courses that you
buy are not making you money and it is
not
for the reason that you think this was
um
kind of prompted because i was tagged in
something where someone was like
i thought this guy sucked and it was
because i heard
some other guy talking about him and so
i just immediately
you know made a judgment and now i
started watching his youtube and i read
his book
i remember all offers you can get it for
99 cents and i was like oh this guy is
pretty legit
and for some reason this has got me hit
my head
racing on a number of different topics
and i tried to write them all down on my
phone so i could make this for you but
i'm going to explain to you why
your course didn't make you money i'm
going to explain how you can try and
use get the best out of courses how you
can know how to
use judgment and when to apply it and
finally i'll explain to you why spanish
is a scam
all right lots of lots of pack stuff
today first off
the reason the course that you bought
didn't make you money
is oftentimes because the thing that the
course taught
is not the only thing that is required
to make money
and so for example if i were to
learn how to do math do i need to know
how to do math
in order to be good at business yes does
knowing math
make me good at business no it is a
subset superset relationship
do i need to know how to write copy to
be good at business
yes if i only know how to write copy
will i make money
no the reality is that in order to get
the first dollar across the bridge
it's much more important to see it as a
bridge from where you are and where
you're trying to go
and each one of the bricks represents a
skill that you'll need
if you do not have one of the bricks you
will not be able to continue to pass
the difficulty in what most people have
is that they continue to reinforce one
brick
and they still have a gap so it's like i
take six different courses on
copywriting but copywriting isn't
the link that is broken in the bridge to
get you from where you are to where you
want to go and get that first dollar
across
or get the increase in dollars across
because if you want to think about it
differently
think about it like a pipe and right now
you've got
let's say thick tubes for the vast
majority of the pipe so you could have
lots of water that's flowing here
but then you have this tiny little tube
over here because it's a weakness
in the system and it affects the overall
throughput from your entire business
right you should think about business in
my opinion like a pipe
right you've got eyeballs over here and
you've got uh
money over here right it's everything
that happens from eyeballs to
headlines to ads to copy to clicks to
conversions to sales
to upsells etc all of that is just this
process where eyeballs get turned into
money and so
if you can just shift your perspective
from like i bought a course on
copywriting or i bought a
course on facebook ads or whatever it is
and i didn't make money
it's not because the course was bad
maybe it was but that's not the point
the point is that it's probably because
you're missing another piece of the
puzzle and that's why it takes so long
for so many people when they get into
the game
and they get so frustrated at the
beginning because everybody tells the
story i bought all these courses didn't
work for me
and then i finally got this thing and
then it all took off but many times that
last course was just the last piece of a
bridge that other people helped you
build
and i think that if you can shift that
perspective you'll stop a having such
negative
you know views around some of the
earlier teachers in your life
and then you'll also be able to just
spot
the gap in your learning and then attack
it ruthlessly and i think that's one of
the things that most people don't do is
they just start continuing to learn
about the things that they enjoy rather
than continue to focus
on the things that they lack now sure
doubling down on your strength from a
large perspective
is a very good idea but the business as
a whole especially if you're a
solopreneur
right or an entrepreneur who's starting
out and only has a team of five maybe 10
people
like the business has to do all of these
things period
so you can be you know skewed in a
certain direction you might be better at
acquisition you might be better at
product maybe better fulfillment
whatever it is right
you might be better at those things than
like learning about that stuff but in
order for the business to be successful
all of these roles have to exist
and even if you don't want to specialize
in it you still need to know enough
about it to be dangerous so you can make
a judgment
on how good someone else is to make to
know if they can fit into your business
so i wanted to cover that first off the
second thing is that
for some reason and actually for some
reason i'll tell you exactly what the
reason is
people get very upset about courses
they buy on the internet and yet for
some reason no one is upset
about the fact that they took four years
of spanish and can't speak a lick of
spanish
hmm why is that because of expectations
it's all it is it's because of
expectations they believe
or maybe you believe i don't know that
if you buy a course
right that immediately you should be
successful
and i'm gonna be here to tell you that
that's not true
and that's because if you just show up
at school
i mean shoot some people enroll in
classes and never show up
is like if you enroll in a spanish class
and never show up
is the is spanish a scam probably not
do you believe that it's possible that
there are good students and bad students
just like there are good teachers and
bad teachers
do you think it's possible that half of
students are below average
half of the people watching this might
be below average hmm
interesting and so if half the people
that take an educational course are
below average
then it would be reasonable that half
the people take a course will get bad
results
now a good teacher can shift that
percentage
and but the thing is is what ends up
happening is it's a bell curve right and
this is studied a zillion times over
classes and humans exist in a bell curve
and so a good teacher can
move the bell curve one direction or
other but they're still going to be the
outliers in the front and the outliers
on the back
and so the reason that people get upset
is because of the expectations they cast
upon what they believe they're going to
get and i think part of that's a fault
of the marketing and the sales process
etc and don't get me wrong i think
there's definitely things that can be
improved there
but i think that you can try and wish
and cast stones
on those people um or you can just
understand going into it that there's a
responsibility that you would have as a
student just like if you went to college
to do a certain amount of stuff and the
reason i'm bringing this up is because i
genuinely am super passionate about
education in general over half the
companies our portfolio our education
and training companies
i believe in vocational type uh training
stuff which is why you know our gym
company is basically
how to run a gym right and um you know
companies that i like are like niche
expertise type things like how to run an
auto shop how to run a plumbing business
like
because that stuff doesn't get taught
anywhere when i look at the educational
system as a whole i think
almost everybody watching this
especially if you're in my channel we
can agree that the education system as a
whole has failed us you know learning
about aztec literature
probably isn't isn't going to serve us
in the real world and so i think that
the reason all of the e-learning is
booming is because
education has failed to keep up with the
times and it's
wildly overpriced the value to price
proposition is one of the most laughable
in the entire world they settled an
entire generation with debt
and no way to repay it you get to the
end of four years you're 100 000
in debt and and you have literally no
more skills that will qualify you for a
job you can get the same jobs before and
after a four-year degree
it's nuts and so the reason that you
know acquisition.com exists for us is so
that we can
hopefully you know my goal is to is to
build the new world of education which
is
how people can actually get skills that
can feed themselves and it was because
i went to some of you guys may not may
not know this but i went to vanderbilt
um i graduated magnetic and bloody in
three years
so i was a good student i don't have the
typical entrepreneurial journey of like
teachers never understood me and like i
i always messed around and couldn't pay
attention like i didn't have that like i
i worked really hard and i got good
grades and despite that
nothing that i learned at vanderbilt at
all
in any class was more valuable than any
course
i've ever bought in e-learning how crazy
that is
right like i've bought courses on
freaking everything i bought courses on
youtube ads
ball courses on on copywriting i bought
courses on sales i bought multiple
courses on sales i bought
i mean everything you can possibly
imagine i bought mentorship or workshops
i bought seminars all of these things
if you were to spend the same hundred
thousand dollars that you spent on a
four-year degree
versus spending a hundred thousand
dollars on the in the e-learning
community on the on the most vetted
courses
and go through them and give yourself
four years to be successful
if you compare the two people it's
apples and oranges it's not even close
in terms of income generation
that they get in that same comparison
which is why i'm so pro e-learning
in general i wanted to hit on this
because i think it's so important
and this is why people get upset and
they buy one course and they think i
didn't make a million dollars and
therefore all e-learning is bad which is
just like such a poisonous thought that
i just hope that if you're watching this
you don't feel that way because
you will like the moment you decide you
don't want to learn in
online it's the new world you don't even
like i don't even know what to say like
it's it's the new world and i make this
channel so that anybody who
who doesn't want to spend any money you
can have access to everything
i've courses for free at acquisition.com
um i'm
publishing 10 books and i'm giving them
away at 99 cents because i can't give
them cheap on
amazon um so that everyone can happily
and i made these as textbooks
so that you can actually know like this
is a this is how you make an offer
right and this is how you can start your
business um and start selling stuff
anyways not not to go more into that but
one your course didn't make you money
because it's probably not the weak link
in your chain
number two you're probably upset about
it because the expectations that you had
was that if i buy this thing i will make
lots of money and that's partially
follow the marketing of the people who
are selling the course so i'll agree
with you there
but overall if you remove that
expectation there's lots of good stuff
defining courses and i've and i've
learned
basically everything i know from courses
and application
one thing that i think is important is
that if you were in a service business
right or you are somebody who's trying
to learn a skill like i said earlier you
have to come a certain percentage the
teacher has to come a certain percentage
and the better the teacher the less
skilled the student needs to be
but at the end of the day if i take a
course or i go into a workshop or i take
you know do
whatever i know because of who i am that
i am going to get
a return on my money because i will find
something to learn
i've learned from bad courses because
i'm like
these are things that i'm not going to
do when i build my course and that has
been valuable to me
and so a lot of people just create
themselves as victim and continue to
play the story
like woe is me you just gotta get over
it because no one cares no one's gonna
help you
like only you are gonna help you if you
keep telling yourself the story it's
gonna it's gonna kill you
let me give you a fun example if you've
ever been to dairy queen
and um i have which is delicious by the
way
for some reason let's say the girl at
the front when she flips the thing
flips your flips your dairy queen shake
right
the ice cream falls out because she does
it bad right
whatever do you then all of a sudden say
screw you warren buffett in your
terrible business one star
or do you think it's possible that that
employee is new
the last piece that i want to say is um
around judging others
and it's kind of what i started with
this thing was
one of the guys who posted this thing
said that
someone else had told him bad stuff
about me this is a rule so i'll try and
share as many of the algorithms that
that layla and i have developed in terms
of making decisions which is
we try and make if-then statements uh
that we don't have to repeat
decision-making processes because
there's a lot of attention and time
and energy to make decisions and so if
you've made one then just
boom that is an algorithm that if this
than that and then you don't have to
make it again and so
it just makes your day faster and easier
because you don't have any emotional
effort so i'll give you one of our money
ones which is no diligence no deal
really simple right and if we don't both
agree we don't move forward
so there are simple things that we've
done over time to just simplify our
decision making process
and so decision making algorithm i want
to give you around people that i have is
that if
i don't know someone firsthand i don't
make a judgment
right and let me tell you a couple
reasons why because there's there's a
couple variables i think are worth
exploring
the first is that who here has thought
to themselves when i look back on my own
past i was an idiot
i do all the time every day right and
sometimes today i think yesterday was an
idiot
right and so if you think back to your
past you're like man that guy was an
idiot right he was so arrogant he
thought he knew
him so much how can i then assume that
right now ten years from now i'm not
gonna look at who i am now and think the
same way
and so i question me's judgment from
five years ago i'm like man
the perspective in which you saw the
world was ridiculous first off
me just me trying to just deal with my
own variable of my own judgment
is shaky at best right and so if i'm
looking at someone i barely will cast a
judgment because
i i'm an idiot half the time and i know
this because of how i know
what i was 10 years ago and hopefully 10
years from now i'll feel the same way
now
now that's variable number one variable
number two
is that the person that you were
listening to also
is an idiot now compared to who they're
going to be and
they probably might be in a certain mood
or they might have certain views about
the world
that are contrary to what i just brought
up earlier and so they're like
if i buy something it should immediately
work now as business owners we want to
take complete responsibility for that
absolutely 100 bar none like our goal
always should be a hundred percent of
people who who do business with me
get value and access to what they paid
so much so that they want to tell their
friends
right that is always the goal and that
is always the ideal that we have to
charge behind
because us blaming our customers is the
stupidest possibly the stupid thing you
could ever do because
it does not improve your business at all
you get you get
no benefit from blaming your customers
but as a customer
you have to understand because if you're
a winner you'll notice that winners are
just taking responsibility for both
sides of the equation right
and so if that person right that that
you're getting the judgment from
isn't a winner and they have stories
that they tell themselves and they might
be an idiot now compared to who they're
going to be in
in x amount of years that if they tell
you so and so
how many times you've heard there's two
sides to a story the more you get around
the business game right like
there's always going to be another side
of the story and so i would have
judgments that i would cast
on people earlier on that prevented me
from doing deals with people that i now
know and i was like i can't believe i
didn't have this person in my life for
five years because
of some post i saw it was so ridiculous
i gave this post
more power than my own ability to make
judgments
as on another person i guess the moral
of the story is if i'm not close enough
to know someone and actually have
conversed with them
then i'm not going to cast a judgment
you know the amount of people who
who go nuts on the fact that i i paid
grant 30 grand for an hour
by the way i paid 120 grand for four
hours was actually what it was and that
was just the first hour
but so if anyone wants to go even more
nuts about it but the point is is that
like
everyone there most people i would bet
have never actually met grant
and so they cast judgment without
knowing who he is
and i think that even if you don't like
someone and i'm not saying
that grant is perfect or by any stretch
of the imagination my god the man has
demons so do i
you miss all of the gold that people can
provide you in your life
by writing off an entire person i think
people are made up of lots of things or
complex beings sometimes you have good
days
sometimes you have bad days and if
someone meets you on your bad days
you're like i was having a bad day but
that's just the judgment that they have
hopefully you're getting the idea here
that there's so many variables that it
makes it
virtually impossible to cast judgment on
someone
unless you have some sort of direct
relationship with them and
even then 10 years from now you're gonna
think you're a [ __ ] right now
hopefully if you grow and so i um
i take 19 grains of salt i take pounds
of salt
with every one of the judgments that i
have and i just try and think to myself
like
is what i am getting from this person
valuable is there something that i can
learn of this person
rather than this person is good or bad
and i think that a lot of times we like
to create binary judgments this person
is good this person is bad
rather than the fact that people exist
on multiple continuums
this was a uh hopefully a perspective
shifting video
that i was inspired to make because of
the pose that i was tagged in i just
hope that everyone can take a quick
second
before you know if you if you buy
something buy it and understand that it
probably won't be the the one link that
you were missing if it is then that's
the thing that creates this crazy
breakthrough
but oftentimes it's just one of the many
bricks that has to be built on the way
to where you're trying to go
and understanding that we're responsible
and that that teachers and students have
a have a
two-sided relationship the better to the
teacher the less bad the student is but
half of people are below average
right and like i said half the people
listening to this are below average so
think about that for a second
and then when we cash judgment on other
people is it really worthwhile or is it
maybe
more useful to say i hate this person
but they're better than me in these ways
and i can learn of them from that
and so that has been some of the some of
the useful shifts that i've had as an
entrepreneur
that have provided a tremendous amount
of value to me in my life and have
helped me
move past things both emotionally where
i didn't get you know an ideal
experience instead of holding on to this
poison
just letting it go because and now at
this point i don't
really experience the poison because i
just don't have the expectation and so i
think that
the more aware we can become this is
just me talking the more aware i can
become of my own expectations
the more uh honestly the happier i am in
life because uh i don't really create a
lot of room for myself to get let down
because i'm not expecting anything it
leaves room to be pleasantly surprised
so anyways if this provided value to you
if this video was a pleasant surprise
hopefully
or shifted some perspectives hit the
subscribe button i can't wait to
see you in the next video lots of love
and uh
for those who don't know us my name is
alex for mozy i own a portfolio
companies
call in acquisition.com right now we do
about 85 million
a year i have nothing to sell you um the
whole goal is that i'm trying to uh
create a billion dollar portfolio and
recreate the middle class in america and
i'm gonna do it one video at a time so
keeping awesome lots of love and i'll
catch you soon bye